[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i would now like to invite scott burch
superintendent of the pearl harbor
national memorial and admiral aquilino
commander
u.s pacific fleet to honor the two
wreaths in the contemplation circle
in remembrance of the attack on oahu 79
years ago today
and salute
[Music]
the official party will return to their
seats and remain standing for the
benediction
a beautifully restored 1972 pitts
s2 alpha aircraft will soon fly overhead
flown by pilot
bruce mays of vintage aviation whose
commitment
to use these annual aerial tributes as a
way to pay tribute to the countless
sacrifices
made by those who have served in uniform
we thank commander bruce mays
united states coast guard retired and
vintage aviation for providing today's
tribute
taps will be played from the
contemplation circle
as we think on the sacrifices of those
who gave their lives in defense of our
country
and echoed forever in our memory from
the
remembrance circle lieutenant marquis
jones
chaplain joint base pearl harbor hickam
will now offer the benediction
[Music]
[Music]
please join me in our benediction
let us pray eternal father
strong to save and swift to hear
the faintest of prayers we pause to
honor those 20th century americans
who took up the struggle during the
attack on pearl harbor
and world war ii to follow
and made the sacrifices to perpetuate
the gift
our forefathers entrusted to us
a nation conceived in liberty
and justice i'm reminded oh god
of the inscription chiseled on the
national world war
ii memorial where president truman's
first message to congress in 1945
is edged it states our debt to
the heroic men and valiant women and the
service of our country can never
be repaid and it's a service
we will never forget sacred texts
proclaims
greater love than no one than this that
they will lay down their life
for a friend and in the face of tyranny
on that december 7th day in 1941
no greater love was shown
now lord we salute those who went above
and beyond the call
send the comforter o god that we might
be reminded
that when we are tasked with facing the
threats to our great nation
we will stand the watch with the same
honor
courage and commitment of those we are
remembering
today now lord as we depart this solemn
place
but never from your sight continue to
grant us victory on land
victory at sea and victory in the air
may the lord bless you and keep you may
he make his face shine upon you and be
gracious
to you amen
[Music]
thank you stand by for rifle
salute
oh
about hey
[Music]
no
ready
[Music]
[Music]
breathe
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ready two
[Music]
orders
[Music]
arms oh word
side boys
before we conclude the ceremony we would
like to once again
recognize all pearl harbor survivors
world war ii veterans
and those who lived through the attack
on december 7th 1941.
on that day and in the years that
followed you superbly executed
your duties at your posts and weathered
the storm of war
it is because of you and others like you
that we enjoy freedom and liberty in
this great country
a grateful nation salutes you today
hand salute
hey two
on behalf of the national park service
in the united states navy
thank you for viewing today's special
observance of the 79th anniversary of
the attack
on oahu and remembering the sacrifices
made by those who served here
on december 7th 1941.
to those who are watching our ceremony
through our online broadcast
we extend a sincere aloha this ceremony
would not have been possible today
without the critical assistance
of the pacific historic parks and the
defense media activity
please remain standing for the departure
of the official party
[Music]
united states pacific fleet departing
[Music]
navy region hawaii and naval surface
group middle pacific
departing
mr scott burke superintendent pearl
harbor national memorial
national park service departing
this concludes our ceremony thank you
for watching
and please enjoy patriotic songs
performed by the united states pacific
fleet band
thank you and have a wonderful day
[Music]
you